brammo deux jours à laquelle il faut
faire un parcours sans rien et posent
des pièges plus personnels chargés des
tic mais qu'at il fait du pédalo dans
l'air ravi car oui les vacances
arrêtez ça suffit ça suffit ça m'arrange
tech et non mais tu vas pas me dire que
c'est tout s'écroule regarde au plus
tard une tête de beaucoup reculé dans le
jeu tarte un genre jamais activer des
pièges et vous allez mourir et c'est que
j'aime et je tiens ta pierre ducout
annonce la deuxième partie du pont qui
n'est pas des moindres
j'ai vu la nos qui était tombé dans la
lave thaler et voilà la meilleure tarte
un retard d'un rien lyon vous et moi il
sait plus quoi faire
allez je saute sur celui-là assez bien
tu t'es bien donner vite et apparemment
tu as fait trop cocardiers mais capoue
s'est aussi fait trop peut être et ce
qui t'arrive dans trois secondes y en a
un de vous trois keira choqué à 2,3 à
limicoles directement chouk un hugo hugo
n'y a qu'une voie technique pour
celui-là pas celle-là on la voit la plus
pure elle est là alors juste là pour moi
la coupure est l'ami cas tu dis qu'elle
est un peu plus loin allez je te fais
confiance
d'où ses actifs ce piège quoi et ma
technique martin c'était quoi ça roule
yards et dernier le dernier je pense que
c'est la même chose mais nous attendrons
bien combien tu es dessus mais non je
peux m'éclater tuant tout quoi ah oui
effectivement
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé l'endroit confie son côté
pour qu'ils ne soient pas le jeu le jeu
en pause etc
on a put un couplet lorient il fait des
va-et-vient la voyez là je me dis oh il
est loin j'y vais quand même bien je
fais en 2g entre mario tama même temps
mais sans battre quelques couches de la
mode
si tu fais du trampoline sur la reine et
tape dans tes mains
bon certains je me sacrifie poursuit la
voici tabesh la technique du tout droit
ça passe ou pas tu m'as fait paniquer tu
m'as dit que tu passes le point c'est
bon je te fais le générique de game of
thrones arrive pour toi at de dansez sur
moi là bas mika j'étais venu d'un coup
seront regardés que flotte annaba
un tas date à la demande des médias
seront bien si tu veux [ __ ] à l'école
a sauté et d'accords hugo du passeport
rouge est d'accord je t'aime les quiches
ou non frau mémoire de me protéger de ce
piège de pigeon hill et un truc pas net
ces pigeons mais que ça se voit oui on
savait que je pouvais le faire confiance
aux comme il est mignon aux attentes et
un peu glauque là 7 seulement la tâche
c'est un truc la commande et le blog
il m'a manqué la reprise est bien là la
coupe était une diversion
j'ai rien compris j'étais lockwood
football qu'est ce qui se passe ici mais
ça c'est impossible si tu me tire dessus
je le dire à ta mère mais bon j'ai caché
que le principe attakus voilà bon ok oui
oui allô oui la maman de du fdp clair ne
tirait dessus oui bah cordialement ont
bien sûr mais michael tu crois que tu as
faim tu es quelqu'un faisant sa [ __ ]
de pluie fait des claquettes là
est ce que quelqu'un sait comment il
était lancée j'ai jamais vu un mec comme
ça il ya la force centrifuge et
apparentés fusent by km taille reste un
méchant ses origines mais bon ça me
casse est le seul qui va pas y arriver
aux amicales à de cette vision j'attends
des vicas au clavier et à la corde est
apte à j'étais tellement panique dur
dans la tête c'était voilà je mets aux
saveurs médias blancs j'ai retiré les
mains de clavier souris le premier qui
passe y vit on oui bon les mecs pour
forte je vous apprends comment feinter
correctement d'abord avancé puis sauter
et retourner en arrière
ok j'ai pensé puisque tiger wood
[Musique]
m